change of plans
[Music]
I want that lab boys whatever it takes
[Music]
oh that undercarriage is filthy they
have bigger problems so how long have
you been ant-man again no huh I just
sort of happened like bad guys like you
I seem to mess it up almost every time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watch for
back
like a partner
[Music]
dr. Pam I actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum rent
that's when he's crazy could be gold so
like walks through walls and stuff
slowly Tech and now she wants to take
over the world or whatever
who would have believed that in your
hour of need you would turn the house
happy because we robbed you do you
remember that's us feeling everybody is
both of you
and man in the wasp teaming up follow my
lead
[Music]
she seems more intense you go low I'll
go high I have wings why would I go low
[Music]
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny
I was partners with Hank on a project
called Goliath how big did you get my
record 21 feet you've 65 feet 65 if you
to our flesh comparing sizes 65
[Music]